what um do you think was the turning
point for you to get sober and because i
just feel like you're more spiritually
just intact like i feel like you're
tapped in yeah man i feel like the
energy is different i'll tell you
something i never told people before in
the interview i've been spiritual my
whole life
and i think instead of owning up to my
responsibility
i would use drugs to kind of
dim my light so to say or turn my gift
down
a little because when it's intense it's
intense when you're in tune you're in
tune
and
it also i had a fear of
people looking at me weird for my
beliefs my belief system
but
everybody has to win their own weight
and right now
i'm winning my own way
like for the first time in my life
i'm proud of myself like i could cry
right now i'm proud of myself i think
about everything i've been through
and i look at where i'm at now
and i always hear people say without a
test you can never have a testimony but
like for anybody that's suffering with
depression or you didn't been through
something in your past that was
traumatic we are not our past
every day you have a chan an opportunity
every day is a new opportunity to find
your gratitude and be better than what
you was
the day before
a lot of people say that they figure
life out when they start moving with
gratitude
yeah you know what i'm saying just being
thankful for
just a little as [ __ ] man because
sometimes i feel like we get so wrapped
up in chasing
what's next we don't live in the moment
we don't appreciate what's going on
right now i was it
i was at this other spot downtown
i was there at
11 o'clock 11 30.
i left at 10 i was like i'm gonna always
be there early
and then i went to the old building the
one across from the whole foods
i was dead 12 45
and then
it just was meant to be and then we came
over here mm-hmm but i used to record
him
well on the other side oh yeah next door
there's uh a studio two doors yeah i
used to recall here i recorded murder
for hire oh wow yes sir
yeah i got this place in uh february
before the pandemic starts this was
years ago yeah yeah but this i know this
place was i mean you know people use
this as a studio still i mean that's
kind of at night it's a recording studio
during the day we do the show here um
beautiful but yeah man uh
it's just been dope to see your growth
and i like i said i got to uh get an
early listen well the album is out now
so when this comes out it's out but i
listen to the whole album front to back
and it feels like
i guess it feels like what you just said
you're proud of yourself it feels like
this was a lot of it felt like a
therapeutic body of work
yeah i did a lot of releasing on this
project
i ruffled a lot of feathers
please find it in your heart to forgive
me i'm so not sorry yeah
even this uh super gremlin freestyle
you're going off five minutes straight
super gentle
yeah it was super general for you i mean
five minutes straight just
delving through everything it was a
release
yeah man it was it just yeah that
freestyle is crazy like uh you know
obviously there's the the parts that
went viral but the parts that didn't go
viral where you're really kind of just
bearing your soul on that thing
people
people gravitate
toward what they want to gravitate
toward
you know i guess
it was like gumbo it had a little
something in there something for
everybody for sure a little ear candy
for everybody i guess
yeah 100 um
how do you feel like um
because you know
i feel like it's 20 22 you know maybe
the last five or six years in hip-hop
has been a real drug-infused vibe you've
been through your struggles with drug
addiction
what is some advice you would give up
and coming artists who maybe where you
were are at where you were maybe a
couple years ago right now that maybe
you want to change their lives
it's not a bad thing
at all
like
these are people that choose to
self-medicate and i don't judge
but
i pray that everybody finds their way
eventually because
when i was on that level i was doing
what people on that level did
i guess so to say yeah you know it's
about frequency it's about raising your
vibration
and
i used to use drugs as more like a
coping mechanism yeah i guess so to say
alcohol too as a vice
i got on alcohol i never drink
i never drank but i got on alcohol like
2018
19
it was like maybe 18 or 19. that's not
long ago yeah and i just
i just i just wanted to feel good i just
wanted to numb everything and not feel
it
and that's what but i'm making it like i
was just a big alcoholic right right
right
because i'm i really can't drink i can't
you have a little tolerance yeah i got a
low tolerance like you give me one or
two shots i'm
you're you're you're on a level he's
over with i'm sauced up yeah so
but i saw alive that i was on live one
time and i was on it i was like man
that's embarrassing look at yourself and
i started talking to myself i'm like
man come on that's not him what were
like the dr like your drugs of choice
like if you were coping like what would
be was it was it lean was it bills i
used to drink a lot of lean
i don't think i ever sat down with you
to do an interview and i wasn't just
fresh off the cup hmm
it's a hard thing to kick right drink a
lot of lean
and
i didn't probably smoke more weed than a
chimney
are you off weed period
yeah i went through my face well i'm off
of it
but
once i finish this this run
i want to go somewhere and just smoke
relax and just relax and just smoke
i just want to smoke i just really want
to just get high and just relax
and not it's nothing like that man i
think about nothing man there's nothing
like getting high and just
looking in the sky right i want to but
i'm just too focused right now i respect
the two so bad but i'm just too focused